let me see if I can take one more call
quickly before we've got to go let's go
to the six one zero area code caller
from six one zero jump right in
tell me who you are and what your
question is my name is Alex I'm from
Pennsylvania and kanye west recently
said he was he wanted to stop talking
about politics I want to know what you
thought about that I think that's good
Alex how old are you by the way I'm
eighteen eighteen okay
Isis or you are you like I guess I'm
trying to ascertain are you in the
generation that likes Kanye Kanye West
music music I'm sort of interested in
like what he was doing ever since he
came out in support of Trump okay so
you're kind of like me you don't care
for the music but you are interested in
his place in politics I think it's good
that he's stepping back he said he was
used to support political positions to
push political positions he doesn't
actually support I feel bad for the guy
I do think that he is having a you know
a mental health situation I think it's
good that he's decided to step back I
don't absolve him of personal
responsibility he decided to go and talk
to Trump and meet with Trump at the
White House and to wear the mag a hat
right I mean ultimately he bears some
responsibility I don't think the guy is
well and I think it'll be good for him
to step away from politics yeah like I
don't think he's a bad person like
bigger so there's some people who like
making it out to be a bad person well I
think that yeah I don't particularly bad
person either I think he just doesn't
know what he's talking about in a lot of
cases and he's struggling he was
manipulated by a movement that's pretty
horrible
yeah all right Alex thank you for the
call really appreciate it thanks to
everybody who called in first time we
took live calls today at the new studio
I do apologize to the 20 people still
holding that I am NOT going to be able
to get you today